hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch two
things for spider-man far from home it's
coming out in just a couple weeks and
kind of doesn't feel that way but surely
it is we have tickets and everything one
called the official new suits trailer
and another one called Mysterio becomes
Avenger scene clip I'm definitely more
interested in the clip so we'll start
with the new suits one first you take
care of the suit I'll take care of music
nice
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah never never doing that again
never getting my next movie more later
on in the same movie I know people will
tend to you know stop after the reaction
so we'll just watch the other one first
and we'll talk about everything compiled
into one from this watch the clip
sarcasm on this earth right yes MCU we
definitely I didn't think I was gonna
have to save the world this summer I
like you here a good kid I was cut this
is a part of me that wants me to tell
you just turn around and run away from
all this and then there's another part
of me that knows were about to fight
what's at stake I'm glad you're here
me too
just always feel like I'm putting in for
danger look just get him inside and keep
in a safe place for just a few hours
they'll be all right it's really nice
have somebody to talk to you about super
girly stuff you don't know betray you
hey anytime Jake Gyllenhaal's acne I
don't know if it's the way it's cut it's
not really buying it but I think I'm not
supposed to buy it I think it's supposed
to seem like he's putting on an act like
the movie to try to sell me more that
he's a hero you know but maybe that's
what they'll do is they'll have him play
it's so suspicious and then by the end
it'll turn out that he no he's just a
good guy yeah his performance seems very
aware that yeah superhero movie you know
what I mean yeah a little bit off that
line about I didn't they're gonna have
to save people this summer you know
you're coming I didn't have to dead
center of summer I think I have a movie
to be in the summer but here I am
thought I was snapped away here Sony
would let me chill for a little bit I
like what they're teasing in terms of
the dynamics between spider-man and
Mysterio of him taking on sort of this
mentorship role they're they're really
raising the stakes for what will most
likely be the betrayal when he finds out
he's a bad guy right that is what it
seems like me well there's always Tony
Stark glasses and has never realized
we're gonna put this all together right
here only needs four more trailers yeah
come on Sony come on you usually Jam
pack your spider-man movies with way
more trailers where they're at man you
get a movies out in two weeks give us
more trailers the hell you doing what I
really like about the marketing switch
for those new suits one is that you see
a happy is a lot more involved in the
action this time around he said dropping
him into explosions in if you slowed
down the clip it's very briefly you can
see he's the one steering the ship at
one point yeah you know I lied about the
music makes me watch the honest trailers
for the MCU and they pointed out how a
lot of characters know a lot of the
release dates of songs
72 sippin artists in the title of them
and I feel like Happy's probably gonna
do one of those nods here time is it
gonna be an unlikely song like Britney
Spears for black played for laughs or is
it gonna be some kind of 70s rock and
roll the Peter doesn't know cuz he
doesn't know the old hits probably a 70s
80s rock and roll you know how MCU likes
to do it this feels like a late in the
game TV spot because like you know what
this honestly reminded me of his so many
action movies or even action leaning
movies have gotten like a late in the
game TV spot where it's like we're gonna
take all the weapons in this movie and
give them names and we're just gonna do
a trailer that's just cycling through
them well they don't have names for
these suits no they just go assic new
new word yeah yeah it's the O is the
original the iron spider the black
spider-man noir ish kind of super spy
suit and then the one that he's pointing
at the end using what looks like stark
tech marking me back a little bit
towards the first Iron Man movie he's
doing it like yogurt style where he's
just selecting everything here yes and
putting together backers do that
[ __ ] instructions are they given to
just do this and we'll insert effects
later and we'll work around your hand
movement yeah do whatever and we'll put
some hands that's pretty much what
they're doing but it looked like his new
suits gonna have a little bit more tone
down on the gadget side I think that
with that complaint of spider-man home
come and how some people thought his
suit had a little too much gadget reaiiy
feel like we're not gonna get the
instant kill here the instant kill arc
has have been completed they t it in
homecoming he uses it as endgame done
and now it's done no more instant kill
ones they're gonna be a moment to use it
in spider-man 6 when Peter who yeah dark
that line no a little tight around the
old web shooters I'm so glad they
finally made a penis joke getting this
yeah and the kind of easily graphic in
your mind penis joke at that and then
family guys had the best one roll that
clip
despite of that when he gets laid oh god
I'm so sorry
that's never happened to me before it's
just you're so attractive then it's been
a while okay and then Sabian MJ that
little image I haven't actually seen any
of the clip that was the first time I
seen a clip from it knowing Sony that's
probably the very beginning or the very
end of the movie no right before the
credits roll it's right when Peter
swings them from the UK back to New York
over the Atlantic oh that's what its
gonna be
wow that's that's gonna be a hell of a
scene it's gonna go on for a fortune
yeah but I'm really excited by her man
far too long I'm like almost 50% done
with the spider-man ps4 game now I've
gotten a little addicted to it I take my
time with games because I can get
carried away like most people where I
find I'm not doing anything else at
night so the past like four days I've
said to sit down to play for 30 minutes
and then I'm there for two and a half
hours so watching spam like really in
the spider-man mindset she's saying all
this I mean like yeah I'm jacked up it's
gonna be a cool movie it's gonna be fun
and it's gonna be light yeah we're gonna
transition just fine anyway guys did you
get your tickets for spider-man far from
home
did you hear end game is getting
rerelease next week which is smart
that's gonna be really small as it
already out of the theaters it's
character lease with like so many more
footage errs on there right drops in
like number 10 last yeah gotta get that
45 mil somehow they got a top of the
avatar Impala also I think it's a good
way to lead in for spider-man far from
home now they're playing the trailer
some theaters played the trailer before
which is so bad so they're gonna play
the endgame trailer again before spider
yeah
well guys if you like this video please
hit that like button and subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell follow us over at our patreon page
over there we do weekly q and A's TV
show reactions stream along several with
reaction highlights included hop on over
there to see what all those shows are
sure one of those you watch and last but
not least let's think of a page for the
day shout outs a man named Melvin X my
dude I haven't
from you in a long time you've stayed
pledged which is okay I'm okay with
being ghosted as long as your credit
card hasn't ghosts at our patreon page
you know what I'm saying this guy's real
name is Tamir and I look up his name
here's what it says you'd like to
control everyone with your influence to
shape things to your own liking kind of
like Mysterio if positive you would
develop high spirituality as you have a
God's protection I could use you in my
life you are a sensitive affectionate
imaginative and cooperative I don't get
that vibe from you either and reply to
me spiritually aware I'm prone to
self-sacrifice that's true you do keep
your card on file you can keep secrets
and are a good diplomat I have revealed
my darkest deepest secrets to you killed
many a youtuber you may have healing and
psychic powers you did tell me about
some things that I've never told anyone
which is very impressive
you are inventive he is an artist
intuitive and extremely methodical he's
helped me out with my kills since your
will is so strong you are hard to
convince hence you don't reply you also
dislike advice like our advice to reply
yeah you love beauty and philosophy then
why is your girlfriend so ugly okay I
Love You Man hopefully check out your
message inbox soon and hopefully you
don't see the shout out and if you have
a girlfriend I'm sure she is beautiful
and philosophical